We're talking a lot about Corona virus today,
not because we are in a crisis pandemic in
the United States right now, but because Donald
Trump's administration is so unprepared and
so incoherent that in the event that we have
an actual pandemic situation in the United
States, we are potentially in really big trouble.
And the cherry on top of this atrocity is
that Donald Trump has put his vice president
Mike Pence in charge of Corona virus and I
really need everybody to understand how ridiculous
and just terrorizing this is.
Donald Trump has cut funding to the CDC.
Donald Trump is underfunding medical research.
Donald from fired his pandemic response team,
which we'll get to.
I could give you this long list.
But then on top of it, he puts Mike Pence
in charge of Corona virus.
Mike Pence is planned to deal with HIV as
governor of Indiana was.
He needed time to go home and pray on what
he was being asked to do.
Pence enabled the spread of HIV in Scott County,
Indiana five years ago, which led to more
than 200 people getting infected.
People came to Pence and said, we need a needle
exchange program.
We need it now.
We can put it in place right away.
Can we do it governor?
And Trump said, uh, I'm sorry, Pence said,
I want to go home and pray on that.
And he eventually signed the needle exchange
into action, but said, I will tell you I do
not support needle exchange as drug policy,
as anti-drug policy.
But, but this is a public health emergency.
So if it's an emergency, you're doing it because
you agree, it'll help, but you actually don't
support it.
I mean, completely incoherent.
The guy barely believes in science.
This is one of the last people that should
be dealing with Corona virus.
And he is the person who will be in charge,
nevermind involved.
This is actually serious.
People will die.
Checkout Donald Trump announcing this yesterday,
talking about how Mike Pennsy, he said Pence
is great on healthcare.
He's expert at the field.
What is he talking about?
I wish this were a joke.
I really do because we're screwed with these
people in charge.
Okay.
Uh, we're doing something else that's important
to me cause he's been a terrific in many ways,
but he's also very good on health care and
we really follow him very closely.
A lot of States do.
When Mike was governor Mike Pence of Indiana,
uh, they've established great healthcare.
They have a great system there.
It system that a lot of lot of the other States
have really looked to and change their systems.
They wanted to base it on the Indiana system
is very good.
Yeah.
Very good on health care.
Uh, States we're following Mike Pence, his
lead when he was governor in Indiana.
Like, could that possibly be true?
I tried to find evidence of States basing
their healthcare decisions on what Mike Pence
did in Indiana.
I couldn't find any evidence of that.
If anybody can find evidence that Mike Pence
was leading the way on healthcare as governor
of Indiana, please let me know.
Here's another clip
and what I've done is I'm going to be announcing
exactly right now that I'm going to be putting
our vice president Mike Pence in charge and
Mike will be working with the professionals
and doctors and everybody else that's working
in the team is, is brilliant.
I spent a lot of time with the team over the
last couple of weeks but they're totally brilliant
and we're doing really well and Mike is going
to be in charge and Mike will report back
to me, but he's got a certain talent for this.
And uh, I'm going to ask Mike pans to say
a few words.
Please.
Thank you.
A certain talent for this.
We are just in such trouble here.
And uh, medical experts have responded to
this totally bizarre press conference yesterday
saying what Donald Trump is telling us is
incoherent.
Trump is incoherent about what he says is
going on and here is Trump again, insisting
we're totally prepared despite having no evidence
whatsoever that we are prepared.
Well telling I guess some kind of joke.
So was Donald Trump doing
wash your hands stay clean.
You don't have to necessarily grab every handrail
unless you have to.
You know, you do certain things that you do
when you have the flu.
I mean view this the same as the flu.
When somebody sneezes, I mean I try and bail
out as much as possible when they're sneezing.
I had a man come up to me a week ago, I hadn't
seen him in a long time and they said, how
are you doing?
He said, fine, funny.
He hugs me.
I said, are you well?
He says no.
Who said I have the worst fever and the worst
flu and he's hugging and kissing me.
So I said, excuse me.
I went, they started washing.
So you have to do that.
You know this is, I really think, doctor,
you want to treat this like your treat the
flu, right?
Whatever happens, we're totally prepared.
We have the best people in the world
now.
Okay.
I, I have to, I've said from day one, I said,
when Trump says I agree with, I will tell
you, I also bail out when people start coughing
and sneezing.
I actually do something at airports that my
girlfriend finds very embarrassing, which
is, you know, those long hallways often at
the airport where you're either walking down,
there's Gates on the left and right and you're
getting to your gate or sometimes to get under
the a tarmac.
You go on these really long hallways to get
from one section of the terminal to the other.
I'll be wheeling my, uh, my, my roller board
bag.
Someone will just cough right into the air,
a foot away from me.
I will just immediately be aligned away from
them and a charter course parallel to the
one where I was, it's totally obvious why
I'm doing it.
It's yes, it's because of the person coughing
without covering their mouth.
My girlfriend gets very embarrassed, but I
bail out as well.
I was at a cafe over the weekend working on
some show stuff.
I sit down with my cappuccino and my bagel
and the guy next to me.
It was sort of like a bar set up with high
stools where you sit, guy next to me starts
a wet cough right into the air.
I just grabbed my stuff and moved.
He gave me a look like I was being made.
No mean you are the problem sir.
You are coughing into the air.
So I agree with Trump there.
He's completely right about bailing out when
people are coughing like that.
But back to Mike Pence running this thing.
I have a hard time imagining a worse person
to run Corona virus for the United States
and that's often the outcome with Donald Trump.
What is the worst possible solution to this
issue?
That's the one that Donald Trump picks.
Mike Pence rejects the scientific consensus
on multiple issues.
How the hell do you put Mike Pence in charge
of this and the, this is the risk.
He disagrees with the intelligence experts
on intelligence.
He believes he knows more than his generals
about the military.
He disagrees with medical experts about how
prepared we are on coronavirus.
It's tragic and I said it before and I tweeted
about it and I'll say it again.
When people say, I'm not into politics, it
just, man, I, you know, I'm into other stuff
very quickly.
We are going to realize here tragically how
much politics is life and death if you didn't
know it already, and I hope that most of the
people in the audience already did know that
we are very quickly going to realize how life
and death politics is.
It's tragic.